there was a point last week or the week
before where Hillary Clinton was ahead
in something like 20-something of all
20-something recent polls and finally
Donald Trump is showing a lead although
only by one within the margin of error
could actually be at I could actually be
that he's losing to Hillary Clinton by a
couple of points in one of the last 39
polls and I'm going to put up a list of
recent polls for you here and what's
fascinating about this is that the the
list is barely readable because it's
such a long list because there are so
many polls in which Hillary Clinton is
winning I mean you have to go back so
far all the way back to July
twenty-third and twenty-fourth for
polling data where Hillary Clinton is
actually losing to trump a couple of
ties in there and you see at the very
top of this image if you're watching
with me Trump plus one however Donald
Trump has definitely been climbing a bit
lately on average uh Hillary Clinton's
average lead now it only
three-point-three percent but nate
silver's website fivethirtyeight.com
actually tracks the probability that
trump or Clinton will be the eventual
winners of the November election and I'm
gonna put up a chart for you again for
people who are watching here will you
will see a blue trend line and a red
trend line and you will see that at a
certain point in early August hillary
clinton's chances of being the winner in
november just exploded all the way up to
somewhere around the high eighties % but
since about mid to later august that
probability has been trickling down from
its high of nearly ninety percent to
sixty seven point eight percent as of
this morning donald trump currently
estimated by nate silver's 538 model to
have about a one-third chance of winning
in november this is a big big change
from what we had at just about three
weeks ago the last thing i want to show
you and this is of course because we
have an electoral college system in the
united states and the national election
is made up of individual elections in
each state what does the electoral map
look like let's take a look at that and
you will see here that currently now
this is a different method this is not
looking at national polling but rather
looking at state-by-state polling and
adding up the number of Delegates of
electoral votes rather i'm still in
primary mode of electoral votes that are
associated with each state currently
electoral dash boat dot-com which has
been doing this for i think at this
point it's at minimum of 12 years if not
16 or even longer Hillary Clinton 323
Trump 197 they only have Ohio as tide
right now which is worth 18 electoral
votes Florida they have it as slightly
leaning towards Hillary Clinton
Pennsylvania one state where Donald
Trump says he could actually win polls
don't seem to suggest that uh and of
course the big big question mark around
some of the mountain time states and
Nevada in pacific time most of those a
number of those also leaning in the
direction of Hillary Clinton right now
so the big picture is state by state
hillary clinton is very very strong
right now we have an electoral vote
system the other big picture is that for
a long long time in this dates back many
many elections the leader at this point
the leader up through august the leader
in early September has one that is
generally what happens here's the
question for the audience that I want to
hear from you about and follow up on
over the next few days what could happen
in the world as a news event that would
give Hillary Clinton a big bump and
basically put this totally out of reach
for Donald Trump and what could happen
that bumps Donald Trump into the lead in
a way that Hillary Clinton may not be
able to uh surmount and uh of course the
conventional wisdom is always a
terrorist attack helps the Republican
candidate we've dispelled to quote to
channel Marco Rubio we've dispelled with
that notion in the past over the last
couple months because Hillary Clinton as
a particularly moderate Democrat and
Donald Trump a zipper particularly
clueless and inexperienced candidate we
may see a sort of different reaction to
a potential terror
wrist attack which of course hopefully
will not happen so let me know answer
that question uh for for me what could
help either one of the candidates